all right I understand we have a mystery
guest exciting is that what an a an
a-list guess I'd say so I'm gonna go get
the mystery guest and bring that person
in all right
just give me a warning so I can slide
these things down for all right is
everyone in place all right we haven't
played this in a long time Robin this
will be fun what I say well you're
blindfolded you should be able to hear
all right I'm now blindfolded completely
I can't even find anything I'm gonna
knock over this water right onto the
board I know it Fred you're not playing
right I am NOT playing oh this is
exciting
Gary says this is an a-list game just
said bring hands and bring em like them
you said him I don't cannot say him Gary
is our mystery guest seated just about
are you George Clooney no yeah Robin uh
he's already perturbed
he's already annoyed since I got a no
answer
I'll pass to Robin are you currently the
member of a band no hmm my turn yeah
it's your turn did you used to be in a
supergroup no all right so you are a
solo artist yes okay are you David Bowie
no huh I didn't think you were oh oh
are you a guitar player No are you a
lead singer yeah cool and you have had
many hit records of course many many
once even had two records in the top ten
at once is that right hmm yeah no that
means you're not harming from Herman's
Hermits solo artist let me think uh
second solo artist you know I know that
supposedly have you ever been Carrie
give me a hint boy am I not getting this
this person has changed his name more
than Fred really geez changed his name
you changed your name yeah why'd you do
that
I was bored with the one name
where are you from that's not English
are you an American citizen no yes
oh you are yeah changed your name
goddamn it change your name
top 10 hits to a lot of times in it
changed your name changed his name
American Susan do you want another yeah
he's a good friend of the farmer
oh is this John Cougar Mellencamp yes
sir ah I'm a good friend of the farmer
as well nice to meet you John